HEALTH CARE SYSTEM COULD
COLLAPSE.
SHANNON?
>> Shannon: TRAITS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WASHINGTON, D.C., MAYOR MURIEL
BOWSER URGING FOR A CLOSE FOR
BARS AND DID NOT SIT WELL WITH
TOM JOHNSON, MANAGING PARTNER
FOR THE
WE WILL NOT BOW DOWN TO PRESSURE
FROM THE MAYOR’S OFFICE OR ANY
GROUP FOR THAT MATTER WHO’S
COVERTLY TRYING TO SHUT US DOWN
TO IT WE FULLY SUPPORT OUR
EMPLOYEES AND PATRONS.
THE MAYOR RESPONDED BY SAYING
THE GROUP MUST COMPLY, AND
JOHNSON UPON THE TELLING THE
WASHINGTON
"THE WASHINGTON POST," I DON’T
HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL TO PAY
THEM.
IT’S LITERALLY GOING TO PUT ME
OUT OF BUSINESS, I’M GOING TO GO
BACK RAMPED UP YOUR TALKING
ABOUT IT WITH STEVE WEINBERG,
FORMER MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF THE
PEACE CORPS.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, SHANNON.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Shannon: THIS IS NOT YOUR
FIRST RODEO.
YOU ARE AROUND THE FIRST BUSH
ADMINISTRATION WHEN THE SARS
EPIDEMIC HIT.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US FOR CONTEXT
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE IN THE MIDST
OF ALL THESE THINGS ROLLING OUT?
>> THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
RESPONSE, SHANNON.
SARS WAS FAIRLY LIMITED.
IT LASTED BASICALLY A FEW MONTHS
AND IT WAS OVER.
WE HAD TO MOVE OUR PEACE CORPS
VOLUNTEERS OUT OF CHINA FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THEY WENT BACK IN.
THIS IS WORLDWIDE.
IT’S NOWHERE NEAR THE END, YOU
HEARD DR. FAUCI SAY IT’S GOING
TO GET WORSE BEFORE IT GETS
BETTER, AND THE GOVERNMENT
RESPONSE SO FAR IS INCREDIBLE.
DR. FAUCI, DR. BURKS OR TWO
FOLKS OUR
I WORKED WITH.
THEY ARE NOT THE BEST IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., THEY ARE THE
BEST IN THE COUNTRY.
IN THE WORLD INFECTIOUS DISEASE
AND VIROLOGY, I HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE THEY ARE GOING TO GET
THIS UNDER CONTROL.
WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THIS AND GET THROUGH ON
THE OTHER SIDE IS A STRONGER
COUNTRY.
>> SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT SAID
AS PART OF THE DAILY PRESS.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> IF THEY ARE ABLE TO GET
VENTILATORS, ABLE TO GET THROUGH
WITHOUT THE LONGER PROCESS OF
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WE HAVE
STOCKPILES WHERE WE ARE ORDERING
FROM AND IS NUMBERS OF
VENTILATORS, RESPIRATORS, MASKS,
AND THEIR ORDER IS PURE ARE
COMING.
IF THEY CAN GET THEM DIRECTLY,
IT’S GOING TO BE FASTER IF THEY
CAN GET THEM DIRECTLY IF THEY
NEED THEM.
>> Shannon: THERE WAS TALK
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS
TELLING STATES, HEY, THAT’S NOT
WHAT YOU SAID, BUT HE DID TELL
THEM, LISTEN, IF YOU HAVE A MORE
DIRECT WAY TO GET THEM INSTEAD
OF GOING TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THAT MAY BE YOUR
BEST OPTION.
WHAT’S YOUR SENSING WHETHER WE
ARE PREPARED ON THAT FRONT OR
COULD BE IN TIME?
>> I HOPE WE ARE.
MY BEST SENSE IS WE ARE.
THE IDEA IS THE RELATIVE
DRACONIAN MEASURES PUT INTO
PLACE LAST NIGHT AND THE CDC
TODAY BY THE TASK FORCE, IF WE
CAN GET THIS CONTROLLED IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO NEED ALL IS VENTILATORS THAT
WE ARE HYPOTHESIZING.
THERE
THEY ARE FOR THE MOST CRITICAL
PEOPLE, THOSE OF US PULMONARY
PROBLEMS, AND WE ARE IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE.
WE’LL HAVE ENOUGH ICU BEDS AND I
THINK WE CAN TAKE CARE OF THE
POPULATION THAT NEEDS IT IF WE
CAN STOP THE PROGRESSION.
>> Shannon: DO YOU THINK WE’VE
DONE ENOUGH WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND CLOSING BUSINESS
IS DOWN TO GET A WEEK AHEAD OR
TO WHERE ITALY WOULD BE AT THE
SAME POINT WHEN WE GET TO THEIR
TIMELINE?
>> I THINK WILL DO A LOT BETTER
THAN ITALY.
YES, I DO.
WE MAY HAVE TO GO FURTHER.
I HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE -- I THINK THEY
ARE GOING TO LISTEN TO THE
TASK FORCE, WHAT THEY SAID
TODAY, THE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
DISTANCING IS VERY VALUABLE,
CLOSING A LOT OF THINGS DOWN,
IT’S VERY VALUABLE.
IT’S AN EXAMPLE, AND I DON’T
NECESSARILY THINK THIS IS 100%
ACCURATE, BUT CHINA, IF YOU LOOK
AT THEIR DATA, THEY HAVE AC/DC
LIKE OURS AND THEY PUBLISH THE
DATA IN THE JAMA, WHEN THEY
CLOSE DOWN WUHAN AND THEY CLOSED
EVERYTHING DOWN, THEY STOP THE
PROGRESSION OF THIS DISEASE
WITHIN A WEEK.
>> Shannon: I’VE GOT TO STOP
YOU THERE BUT WE KNOW YOU’RE
COMING BACK NEXT HOUR.